[Music]
[Applause]
kids welcome to SM Castle I'm Kevin
Smith thank you for being here for the
second annual SM Castle Film Festival uh
whether you're a filmmaker or just a
film fan uh thank you for coming out and
supporting us uh have you had a good
time time over the course of the
weekend all of your thanks and
appreciation go to the left ladies and
gentlemen uh the hard work of the SM
Castle Film
Festival belongs uh all the credit goes
to SM Castle keeper Ernie Odon I'll give
it up for him one more
[Music]
time Ernie indeed all right um I I'm not
a big Awards guy uh in beginning of my
career they used to give them to me and
[__] now they won't give me any but uh
but you know the award for me like you
got to realize when we went to Sundance
with clerks I didn't expect to win an
award at all the award was like oh my
God we're one of the films at the
[__] Sundance Film Festival so for me
like and this isn't just like saying it
a nice thing for people that aren't
going to walk home with the trophy
tonight you won you made your [__]
art man it lives forever so you've
already
won everybody in the room who's taking a
step toward art has already won you're
all [__] winners that being said some
people are going to get some trophies
but that don't that don't make them
better than anybody else man that just
means that we got a panel of Judges who
watched the nominated films and made
decisions based on that accordingly uh
me and Ernie want to thank our judges
give it up for them they're listed in
your
program
um you know they went through everything
and made their best uh choices and
that's what that's what the awards are
given based on today so if you don't win
an award kids trust me [__] that
means jack [__] um if you do win an
award oh my God you're [__] blessed
no if you do win an award you're going
to receive a pretty cool looking award
look at that [__] man you can get a
golden
calf um all right kids let's get going
with this man uh what I'm going to do is
uh we're gonna put the categories up
behind me I'm gonna read all the
nominees and stuff and then I'll read
the winner winner comes up gets one of
these trophies we're gonna take a
picture on stage uh Tom's here to take
our photo give it up for
Tom uh and then you'll have the mic uh
to say some stuff and then [__] off and
then we do it again and again till all
the awards are gone um all right kids
here we go man the awards uh for the
second annual SM Castle Film Festival
begin with best actor in a short drama
uh the nominees are Richard kind Hitman
secrets of
Lies Eduardo Robinson
triggered Erica camarano blue
[Applause]
fire Ivon Chapman dragon
fruit and is it Richard
Rell what is it really that's an e not a
see my bad Richard reallyy
peries and the winner for best actor in
a short drama goes to Erica camarano
Blue Fire come on
[Applause]
up the trick is to go fast enough that
the Applause don't [__] die
or thank you turn around take
[Applause]
oh my
gosh wow this guy is really cool um it's
just first of all I want to thank my
co-star co-producer writer director Nick
Ronin who yes um wrote this beautiful
film and this part for me and as an
actor when you find your people and your
community um it's just such a blessing
and Nick you continue to be uh one of my
best friends and a blessing so thank you
um I want to thank my family who
supports me to be an artist and make
movies and I just such a hard time in
the world and I just want to say like I
love being an actor I love being a
Storyteller and I think we have so much
power to um convey empathy and uh
compassion and that what we do is really
important work in the world so thank you
for this and I hope we all continue to
make movies thank
you okay best actor in a short comedy
your nominees are Tony Barton for sweet
juices shiron woo for sweet
juices Nathan Byron for exstasy
Langston Fishburn for stalled
and Alexis Swinton for lov's baby
soft uh the winner of the best actor in
a short Comedy Award goes to chirang wo
sweet
[Applause]
juices not
here shit's mine we'll be auctioning
this off later on put that right put it
right there congratulations Shang yeah
right there right there right there oh
that's good that's perfect oh yeah thank
you uh best short comedy folks here we
go best short in the comedy category uh
sweet
[Applause]
juices loves baby
soft
ecstasy
stalled and finally
subtext uh and the winner of the best
short comedy division award is stalled
kids come on up get your
[Applause]
award
all right all right uh thanks so much
Kevin Smith and uh thank you the crafts
and crew of stall thank you Langston he
unfortunately cannot be here thank you
Brett my partner and there we go thanks
don't touch
me uh thank you so much we made a movie
where I stuck my best friend in a toilet
stall for a week and kept spraying him
with sweat and blood and it was worth it
so thank you so much guys really
appreciate
it
uh okay best short drama your nominees
are Hitman secrets of
Lies
triggered dragon
fruit the Lost
weekend and
peries and the award for best short
drama goes to Hitman secrets of Lies
[Applause]
kids thank you so
muches thank you thank you uh so a time
ago in a Galaxy near nearby somebody uh
said that we could make movies and we
didn't have to get other people's
permission so I just want to thank you
so much Kevin because um I I and none of
us would be here without you so thank
you
um and also we would none of us would be
here without any of our friends who no
matter the crazy ideas we have they
always support us no matter what and my
buddy who's been making movies with me
since junior high school Dan H is here
he's a he's a cop and I just want to
thank all all the friends out there and
you guys can do whatever you want
because he has a lot of PBA cards for
all you guys so thank you all so much
thank you thank
[Applause]
you just funny because I told Ernie I
said we should give out free weed with
the
awards nuts I retired years ago oh good
to know [__] free weed after the show
all right kids here we go best edit best
editing Ed sure um this is award
presumably for editing and here are the
features the nominees are sweet
juices dragon
fruit blue
fire dead
Enders and Snow White dies at the
end
and the award for best editing goes to
Sweet
[Applause]
juices
no they're not here not here all they're
Australia fair
enough we should give it to the next one
down for
attendance uh okay best cinematography
kids we congratulate sweet juices uh
best cinematography here you go your
nominees are blue
fire that's a
[Music]
wrap Snow White Dies at the
End Dragon
fruit and hitman's secrets of Lies the
award for best cinematography kids goes
to dragon
fruit
uh Hey guys um I accept this award on
behalf of my DP Henry heurst France
who's this 9 foot tall Englishman I met
in the pandemic and uh I don't know this
this is a meticulous infuriating son of
a [__] and without this guy this film
would not exist he's the best most
reliable collaborator I've ever had so
I'm honored to accept this on his
[Applause]
behalf okay here we go kids original
music your nominees are loves baby
soft for the safety of
Theo
the ghost
light and I mustache
you and the award for original music
goes to I mustach you come on
[Applause]
up
thank you um I accept this award on
behalf of Lon Z raphaeli my kickass
composer for putting up with me driving
him nuts and being super meticulous and
I thank SM CLE for accepting our film
and thanks
guys
okay best
Ensemble your nominees are Hitman
secrets of
Lies Home
Free the 44th chamber of
Shaolin
ecstasy and dead Ender
and the winner of the award for best
Ensemble goes to Hitman secrets of
[Applause]
Lies two pictures that's
right this one we do without our tops
time third one all new okay
de uh I was blessed with the most
amazing cast uh uh we had Richard K
Peter rer K Karen Allen William Sadler
these were all heroes of mine and they
agreed to do me the the biggest favor
they made me a better director and um
actors are the soul of Cinema uh and and
I thank every actor for allowing us to
uh capture that so thank you thank
you uh kids now we're up to best
documentary and to present the award for
best documentary is somebody very
important to me and of course uh thusly
to SM Castle Film Festival uh 30 years
ago 12 days ago 30 years and 12 days ago
um we had a screening of clerks at the
ifm the independent feature film Market
uh in New York and it was October 3rd
11:00 a.m. on a Sunday and that was like
the screening I was hoping to sell the
movie at or at least get people there
who could move and shake it into the
future or whatever nobody was there
whatsoever um except most of cassid crew
and then this one guy who got up on a
Sunday morning um to check out the movie
which he said had the worst photo in the
catalog it looked so amateurish he felt
bad for the movie and he was like I'm
going to go see that movie and that was
clerks man and he exposed that movie to
the world without this gentleman we're
not standing here today at all man give
it up for Bob
[Music]
[Applause]
Hawk
hell best
documentary this is not an alphabetical
order I had already written all the
titles in alphabetical order but I'm
going to read The order they are on the
slide uh life after The Neverending
Story of all the Gin
joints in the night I remember your
name an American pot story Oaker
Dam
and I just want to add one thing I've
watched almost all all the
documentaries and I was quite
impressed I don't feel I wasted a
minute and one thing that filmmakers are
learning more and more is to
know how long your film should be and I
think every film has its own length and
I was very
impressed with
the general
savviness of the films I
saw and now without further Ado the
winner is Life After The Neverending
[Applause]
Story
w sorry I let the you did what the
[__] first thank
you
[Applause]
oh well I wasn't expecting to win so I
don't know what to say um thank you
everyone for making every us feel so
welcome at the festival um thank you to
Ash and Bob who came all this way and
for ash to put up with me for four years
to try and make a documentary about one
of the most iconic 80s children's movies
um and yeah thank you all for being you
and the award and yeah thank you I don't
know what to
[Applause]
say okay moving right along my friends
we are up to best actor in a feature
comedy the nominees are Santiago
Santiago Vasquez kick
me Ryan County Home
Free Aaron Prager cannibal
comedian Daniel vankirk wine
club and Taylor Ortega wine
club
and the award for best actor in a
feature comedy goes to Santiago Vasquez
kick
[Music]
[Applause]
me okay I'm Santiago better looking
brother he left us 35 years ago went to
Kansas chasing after a woman uh he's
done great since retired cop martial
artist and now look at this Danny Tre is
getting old he's
[Music]
next uh okay now we're at best actor in
a feature drama the the nominees are ver
nesca Snow White dies at the
end Gerard goril dress
code Mario Mayo I'll Crush
y'all and Alejandro deur T Alta
California the winner of the best actor
and the feature drama award goes to
Mario Mayo I'll Crush
[Applause]
y'all oh right on Mario's not here we
accept
this we're keeping it um that's a lot of
shipping that is that truly is man um
okay we're at best screenplay right now
kids and your nominees are Brett aoff
and Eric Rich for
stalled will Swain for sweet
juices Rob BBY Brian for
perges Elias Panos Hitman secrets of
lies and Olivia holler
subtext and the winner for the best
screenplay award is Robbie Bran perges
come on
[Applause]
up
[Music]
this is incredible this is so awesome um
I I just uh I wanna first of all I want
to thank Ernie to pull off something
like this is amazing um amazing and and
um I want to thank all the staff who's
been incredible um to win a screenplay
award when this dude is the most amazing
writer and to be in that kind of
category is off the hook so I get thank
you thank you and thank you to the jury
who obviously picked me for this um I
want to um I want to thank my beautiful
wife Christy who produced this with me
who's always there and my sister and my
brother-in-law who are so
supportive
um all all the filmmakers
congratulations on everything you did
eight years ago I walked into a doctor's
office and they said I had stage four
cancer now I'm holding this this is
awesome thank
[Applause]
you okay kids we are up to Best Director
um and just to be fair I left myself off
the list
um your uh nominees are uh and and if
I'm butchering names please jump in and
and uh uh and help me out here uh saan M
and will Swain sweet
juices Jay Brown dragon
fruit Aaron Brown Thomas
[Applause]
subtext Elias am I saying it right
plagianos PL plagianos thank you Hitman
secrets of
lies and and dead Enders by Fidel Riz
Healey and the Best Director award goes
to Jay Brown dragon
[Applause]
fruit
I'm pretty hung over to be up here two
times um H [__] I I don't know what to
say this is um pretty overwhelming like
the amount of your DNA I have in me and
I hear how that sounds and I say it out
loud yeah yeah yeah like to to get this
from you is really surreal
um this film was really hard it uh just
about broke me and I've kind of been in
a funk since I finished at the start of
the summer and uh this has been a really
rejuvenating experience I met so many
rad people got really drunk with some
really rad People Too Many Times um you
guys are awesome I'm I'm from Canada you
guys have been wonderful hosts so thanks
for having me um this is
amazing
kids just for the record there is none
of my DNA in
him I pull out all the time I I was
raised Catholic that's how we
roll U all right folks here we go best
horror um your nominees are the
Q Split
Second snake dick
if we had an award for best
title uh there's something in the
silence and dead
Enders and the award for best horror
goes to dead Enders come on
[Applause]
up
I got to get one like
this got my own little movie now uh I am
terrible at speeches thank you so much
Ernie and the whole mod Castle team and
all the jurries of course Kevin thank
you for having us all our weird little
gas station movie at your Festival I
thought it would be very fitting here we
decided what if a gas station movie had
monsters in it and we remembered Tremors
existed so we just said it at night
um uh this movie was a lot of fun we
shot in South Texas just keep making
movies and put monsters in them because
and'll make them more
[Applause]
fun
and you said you weren't good at
speeches uh best animation folks your
nominees are the voice in the
hollow uh V vdr LK family family of
[Applause]
vilac the latest Story Ever
Told sucks to be the
[Applause]
moon and unicorn
boy the award for best animation goes to
the voice in the
hollow be surprised if they were here is
that right uh the filmmakers are from
Africa so Ernie's like I don't think
they're
here it goes Atlantic Highlands Leonardo
Africa um we accept it in their honor
and we'll get it to
them that's cost me like $75 a ship
there you know if you ever go to the
sundance's film festival you never hear
Robert Redford go that's going to cost
me 70 bucks to [__]
ship buy a t-shirt godamn
it true great commercial buy a SM a SM
gastle uh Film Festival t-shirt it make
Ernie very
happy we'll for we'll be able afford to
send uh the award to the folks in Africa
for the voice in the hollow otherwise
it's just going to sit here
forever um okay kids we're up to best
drama uh feature here we go your
nominees are Snow White Dies at the
End dress
code I'll Crush
yall and ala
California and the winner of the award
for best drama feature is I'll Crush
y'all not
here they're not here but they sent a
nice little care package a few t-shirts
and bumper stickers and [__] and they
said thanks for including us we're
keeping that
award uh here we go last award of the
night there's only one left on the table
kids there it is and here we go
it is uh best comedy in the feature
division here we go your nominees are
kick
me wine
club cannibal
comedian Ronald's little
Factory and Home
[Applause]
Free and the winner of the award for
best comedy is feature is kick me come
on
[Applause]
[Music]
up Gary hoggins he met my brother what
15 years ago at a Kansas City Library my
brother was undercover so he had his
undercover Persona Carlos and he
couldn't believe this guy was going to
was asking for a obscure Japanese film
the rest is history they've been to
Sundance now they're here where he's
from thank you thank
you uh folks those are all the trophies
that we have to give out now I think
there is a wine what's the wine bar
after after what time is that begin 8:30
8:30 so kids
8:30 you went last year you went an hour
and a half here oh is that right tell us
some stories
K hour and a um oh so you're the is are
we early is that it it's it's a very
it's
rare it's the Rarity I thought I thought
I didn't I thought we were supposed to
move things
along oh my God I would have told an
anecdote between each award and [__]
we're going to do the uh nominee we'll
bring them up to a little we're do do
the thing afterwards okay so yes so what
we're gonna do is um I guess the wine
bar thing opens at what time 8 8:30
maybe maybe it can happen earlier my
mind is sh my mind is
shot 8:30 thank you um but uh what we're
going to do is hold the folks that uh
got some trophies uh stay behind we're
going to take a big group shot with all
y'all and stuff uh everyone else thank
you so much for coming out thank you if
you're a filmmaker
well if you're a film fan thank you for
supporting the film festival if you're a
filmmaker thank you for choosing
creation over destruction in this life
telling a story letting them know who
you are making a damn thing um I
honestly I I don't say this uh lightly
and it's not something that's just made
said to make people that don't walk away
with a goofy cow trophy feel good
everyone who [__] made a thing won
you've already won man uh so please keep
making [__] it's the best we could do in
this weirdest of and best of all
possible worlds um if you have the
inclination to be a Storyteller lean
heavily into that the world needs your
voice man uh they want to be distracted
from everything that's going on
including all the internal things that
that go on with folks as some folks
probably know because I talked about it
incessantly uh I went away for a while
earlier this year and stuff for some
mental health reasons uh you know what
made life easier you know the road back
for me was movies the same movies that
made me want to be a filmmaker as a kid
I've reinvested my time in and they kind
of made me whole again they were like
little uh the Harry Potter penses or
even better than that they weren't
penses they were um was that thing that
Voldemort had all his pieces in they
were [__]
horcruxes which is weird I don't want to
compare myself to Voldemort but still
cool idea that you can leave little
parts of yourself along the way and then
collect them back at a later date and
stuff movies were that for me so your
movies are going to be that for somebody
everybody here has made a film that is
going to be all the difference in some
person's life outside of the filmmaker
themselves um that is a beautiful an
amazing thing if you have that ability
to tell a story you have an ability to a
lot of people don't have and wish they
could tell do for themselves so if not
just for you if you don't feel it just
for your own sense of vocation or
calling if you have a gift like you have
and you're here and you're a filmmaker
make those films for all those people
who can't who never will who just don't
have the thought the ability and [__]
don't pity those people because they
could do other things maybe you can't
but you could do something that makes
them feel you could do something that a
lot of people wish they could do Express
themselves that's the gift you all have
as storytellers keep expressing
yourselves because when you express
yourself you're expressing it for
somebody else as well you're making life
that much easier for somebody you'll
never [__] meet cuz they identify
with what you're saying and they're like
thank you I'm not alone in this world
and [__] keep telling your stories and
keep coming back to the SM Castle Film
Festival which will always be organized
programmed within an inch of its life
and then held together by his two
[__] hands our SM Castle keeper Ernie
oon will give it up for him ladies
Gent
kids if you want a trophy stick around
otherwise everyone else be very careful
on that good night we'll see you over at
the wine bar later on thanks for being
here